hi I am giving the Kapadia edge of
calculus and algebra wolfram and this
morning at 11 o'clock I will do a talk
with Adam Stravinsky a senior developer
on asymptotic solvers I hope to see you
there
so it's another joint talk with Devendra
and we will be talking about asymptotic
solvers so here's the plan for the talk
first I will talk about asymptotic solve
and then the vendor I will talk about
asymptotic our sole value and asymptotic
saw some so these are new functions in
in version 12
so first asymptotic solve so again
suppose we want to solve the equation in
two variables for y as a function of X
so we can get global a simple global
algebraic solutions who is solve and we
can get the solution over the reals and
using asymptotic solve we can get local
solutions near a specified value of x so
this gives us all complex solutions as
we have serious in this case and we can
also ask for solutions that are real we
have to specify that they are real for
positive x near zero for negative x we
would have to use Direction option so we
have three solutions and we can check
that the asymptotic solutions will
approximate algebraic solutions near
zero for positive values here is the one
of the roots become complex here near
zero there are three roots and they're
well approximated so let me talk about
what are the solvable cases or what
cases can we solve at that time so first
the the nicest case the regular case the
case of non singular points of systems
of analytical equations so we will use
analytic implicit function to RM
this one this grm is true for X&Y of
arbitrary dimension so if the derivative
is inverse with respect to y is
invertible then locally we have exactly
one solution and this solution is
analytic so here's an example with an M
dimensional one here is a function that
check function is zero at zero its
derivative is not 0 so we should expect
one elliptic solution and did we get a
power series with integer powers and we
can check that the solution is a good
approximation for where the function is
pretty difficult to tell them apart so
let's try an example with now and three
dimensional and m2 so variable X is
three dimensional variable Y is two
dimensional so we have two equations we
check that the equations are zero at
zero and that the determinant of the
derivative is not 0 so again we can
expect analytic solution and there is
the solution it's a power series now in
three variables and let's let's do this
trick with with substitution of new
variable times x times each of the
variable two since we don't have right
now multivariate serious mathematical
that's what we do to simulate
multivariate serious and we can see that
substituting the solution into the
original equations gives us something
which is of all
t to the third power we asked for the
third order solution here so it indeed
satisfies the equations we cannot plot
it which will be five dimensional so the
next next case that solvable singular
points of analytic equations now we can
notice that this works only if x and y
are one dimensional so that's a much
narrower case so if we have an analytic
mapping from C to C the function is zero
at a B and the first K minus one
derivatives are zero the case derivative
is not 0 then locally the solution is
there are K solutions and the solutions
can be represented as we saw serious so
serious with fractional exponents so
here here is a function we are solving
for Y in terms of X let's see that at 0
the function and its first three
derivatives are 0 the fourth derivative
is not 0
so we can expect for solutions that are
with a serious
and asymptotic solve should shortly give
that give us a solution here they are
and indeed there they have fractional
powers we can also ask for real
solutions for for positive value of x so
here say we have just two real solutions
and we can check again that their
approximate the exact solution is pretty
well so what's the next solvable case
singular points of algebraic curves so
now we can we can make Y
multi-dimensional but at the cost of
assuming that all the equations are
polynomial and in this case we also get
with our serious solutions so here's an
example with X&Y one-dimensional you are
the real solutions and here are the real
solutions with direction from below so
depending on which direction we are
approaching from we'll get different
numbers of number of solutions and and
different solution different serious and
let's see the so the exact curve is the
blue curve the try volume and we got the
approximations of the solutions near
zero here the singular point let me show
the example with an equal 4 so we have
three equations in four variables so we
can get solutions for three variables as
with our serious in in the remaining one
variable and we can substitute back into
the equation take serious to to check
that that we get the correct result
okay so the next solvable or the the
next slightly different problem that we
are solving we we are looking for
asymptotic solution near a given value
of the independent variables so so what
we are checking before we are specifying
both the value of x and the value of y
now we are just specifying the value of
x and looking for all the values of y
for which there is a solution and this
requires the equations to be polynomial
in the dependent variable so that we can
guarantee that there are finitely many
solutions so it has to be polynomial in
Y and C be analytic in X and we got with
a serious solution we check that it
satisfies the equation and here here we
try a system of three polynomial
equations again one one independent
variables but three dependent variables
and we get several solutions that are we
so serious and we can back substitute to
check that we get zeros up to the
specified order
right so the last syllable case so now
we are all those situations we are
looking at regular points of the
equations now we are looking at singular
point of equation so suppose we want to
solve an equation for this equation
right so it's an x-block equation so
it's X plug in terms of X the variable X
the independent variable and polynomial
in terms of Y and we want to solve it
near infinity so infinity will be a
singular point of this equation it's not
analytic near X going to infinity and
what we can hope for in this case is
solutions that are explode functions in
X and are so they are they're actually
real x-block functions plus 3x plus 5
functions time I so let's let's see what
the solutions look like right so if we
expand it we can see that there is a
part a real part and an imaginary part
and each of them is a real x-block
function and this just gives us the real
solution so the just one the last one is
real and we can check that indeed near
infinity we get a good approximation so
the blue line is this the is our
asymptotic solution the yellow line is
the exact solution and we can see that
near zero it it's a different solution
then it jumps and then it's pretty much
equal to our as Bill acceleration we
cannot even see the difference because
it's everything is exponential here so
so it's the difference disappears pretty
far
so that's all I have but no Devendra
will continue with this greatness in
politics hello hello okay so I'll talk
about asymptotics and discrete
asymptotics inversion 11.3 we had this
idea of continuous imparting so we had
functional differential equations and
integrals and now in version 12 we have
functions for difference equations and
sums and although the discrete game case
came second there's a good reason so
first of all consistent onyx works and
things like physics fluid dynamics and
let's say special functions but if you
go discrete asymptotics you out into
computer science number theory
combinatorics so the whole world has
changed when you do continuous importing
so it could be at 0 1 infinity very like
if you do discrete asymptotics you
always infinity because makes no sense
to talk about sequence at 30 just put
the value in any get the answer so one
last point that although the two are
different the discrete case relies on
the continuous case for many kinds of
classifications so if you know consist
asymptotics you pretty much know this
the discrete case as well so some simple
examples of discrete asymptotic so let
me begin now with asymptotic or small
values so years a difference equation
you can see that the one is much larger
than 1 over n cube so when you solve it
you get back basically kind of Taylor
series at infinity you plug in a value
for the constant C one plot it and just
for comparison look at how beautiful the
asymptotic series is and simple and how
difficult the exact solution looks so
that's a dramatic centra fication so
that's a Taylor case and then on to kind
of the Frobenius case from differential
equations from a course on differential
equations so your what have
this you gotta Frobenius solutions the
differential equation is going there is
no a little slow so faster so then you
get a Frobenius solution here's the plot
goes much faster now so in the in this
case you have a square root of n which
is the sign D to go to frobenius
solution it's going to blow up and
that's the square root of n turn okay so
from Frobenius on to the irregular
singular case and this difference
equation I'm sure you all know it's just
a difference equation for gamma so do
you expect to expect the Stirling
formula and lo and behold there's what
you get back so you have ordinary point
regular single point here ago single
point just like differential
differential equations you plot it and
you find that it's really quite hard to
plot because you have a very very fast
growth rate okay so let me plot it over
here and the curve just shoots up
rapidly because it's moving very very
fast
okay now question is why don't I have
initial values over here
well the story of this goes back to work
off and conquering people of that so
here's a sequence of involutions
from community rings and I can use fine
sequence function to work out the
difference equation for it but then I'm
stuck and the reason I'm stuck is
because basically what is happening is
that you have initial values at one end
you want to approximate the other end
there's no way to do it and so a
polished makes question answers you have
to use an approximation over here I'm
sure Birkhoff knew it I'm sure
Durant's oil burger nuit and all you can
do over here is to compute an
approximate solution to this problem you
can see got a decimal point over there
which is going to let you do things
it's quite hard competitions got to go
into limit workout leading term and then
work out the asymptotic but it's done
that lets prompt you by drones I'll
burger from the 1980s he spends 10 pins
we can do now it half line now so that's
the approximate value 4000 and here's
the exact value and he see all is fine
huh
ok so before I leave the topic something
on perturbation problems we got a
parameter epsilon and what happens over
here you have a solution which has a
parameter in it in the answer and the
exact solution is a geometric sequence
but the approximations have got some
kind of peaks in them okay so on to the
next theme which is asymptotic some now
you know for version seven we actually
did a really nice job of asymptotes of
summation and I thought there's nothing
more over here so at that point we've
done every single algorithm we knew
about and I was not too keen on doing
this function at all but I have learnt a
lot so here's the first example where
you have a kind of rational sum 1 over K
square plus 1 and ask for an asymptotic
and I get back the series at infinity
now in this case of course there's an
exact formula from some itself and if
you do a series expansion of that then
you get back in just the same result not
very interesting but the Polycom of
function in discrete calculus plays the
same role as the logarithmic function in
continuous calculus so if you integrate
a rational function you get logarithms
if you integrate if you sum it you get a
polygamous lightly harder question
here's the hew rational sum 1 or 2 raise
to K plus 1 and now we use the Euler
Maclaurin formula which actually
computes the integral as an
approximation for the sum the problem is
that even oil and you it that there's
one Euler gamma for every
and the oil again for this sum is Q
polygamous so when you do asymptotes of
sums you need to invent one boiler gamma
for every situation and that's the one
for this one okay now let's try the
numerical values and you see they give
quite a nice approximation so here's the
exact answer and you could have pretty
nice approximation and as last example I
won't take up an infinite sum now this
example we cannot do in sum I searched
hard it took me some months to find but
I found it okay so this example works
using a technique due to Philippe Julie
and there's a Mellin transform
computation with the parameter X goes in
Mellin transform space sums over there
does restrict competition comes back all
that in one line it's a beautiful day by
flagella and it takes a bit of time
because the hard computation but we have
melon transform the code rest of you got
everything and it will come back with
the answer in just a minute okay but the
main point is this is a really really
good approximation as I'll show in just
a minute
okay so so here's the approximate value
here's the numerical value and they look
quite nice and simple okay so I am done
and the main point is that for version
12 we have discrete asymptotics and
algebraic asymptotics and now in version
12.1 we won't put all together and have
one massive asymptotic function which is
everything for you just put your
difference equation differentially what
do you like it'll go and do it for you
and then we are done okay thank you very
much
[Applause]